right storage on thank you very much hey  let's talk some hockey now the Golden  Knights are skating through phase two  with phase three now less than a month  away but right now players were skating  at City national which by the way is  open to the public  players are on the I six at a time in  the facility but coaches will be able to  get on that ice pretty soon and for  those two hub cities we should here this  week which ten of which two of the ten  will be picked Eastern Western  Conference teams nothing decided yet but  some Canadian reports have Las Vegas is  ahaab we'll also see that Coover Toronto  also mentioned his frontrunners in fact  one national reporter in Canada say net  NHL is near let's list down to six now  so we'll see hey a big